welcome everyone this screencast kicks
off our unit on analysis methods in NLP
in the previous unit for the course we
were very focused on behavioral testing
and we looked in particular at
hypothesis driven Challenge and as
adversarial tests as a vehicle for
deeply understanding how our models will
behave in especially unfamiliar
scenarios what we're going to try to do
in this unit is go one layer deeper and
talk about what I've called structural
methods including probing feature
attribution and a class of
intervention-based methods and the idea
is that we're going to go beyond simple
behavioral testing to understand we hope
the causal mechanisms that are guiding
the input output behavior of our models
in the previous unit I tried to make you
very aware of the limits of Behavioral
testing of course it plays an important
role in the field and it will complement
the methods that we discuss but it is
intrinsically Limited in ways that
should worry us when it comes to
offering guarantees about how models
will behave
to make that very Vivid for you I use
this example of an even odd detector let
me walk through that from now taking a
slightly different perspective which is
the kind of illuminated feeling that we
get when we finally get to see how the
model actually works but recall this
even odd model takes in strings like
four and predicts whether they refer to
even or odd numbers so 4 comes in and it
predicts even
21 and it rightly predicts odd 32 even
36 even
63 odd and this is all making you feel
that the model is a good model of even
odd detection
but you need to be careful you've only
done five tests now I show you how the
model actually works and it is
immediately revealed to you that this is
a very poor model we got lucky with our
first five inputs it is a simple lookup
on those inputs and when it gets an
unfamiliar input it defaults to
predicting odd once we see that we know
exactly how the model is broken and
exactly how to foil it behaviorally we
input 22 and it thinks that that is odd
but then we get a second even odd model
it passes the first five tests it makes
a good prediction about 22. good
prediction about 5 and 89 and 56 and
again your confidence is building but
you should be aware of the fact that you
might have missed some crucial examples
and again when I show you the inner
workings of this model you get
immediately illuminated about where it
works and where it doesn't this model is
more sophisticated it tokenizes its
input and uses the final token as the
basis for predicting even odd that is a
pretty good theory but it has this else
Clause where it predicts odd and now we
know exactly how to foil the model we
input 16 and it thinks that that is odd
so it was really the point at which we
got to see the internal causal
mechanisms that we knew exactly how the
model would work and exactly where it
would fail Now we move at last to model
3 Let's suppose that it gets all of
those previous inputs correct is it the
one true model of even odd detection
well we can keep up our behavioral
testing but you should see by now that
no matter how many inputs we offer this
model we will never get a guarantee for
every integer string that it will behave
as intended for that kind of guarantee
we need to look inside this black box
but of course in the modern era of NLP
models they're hardly ever as easy to
understand as the symbolic programs that
I was just showing you instead our
models look like this huge array of
birds nests lots of internal States all
connected to all the other states
completely opaque they consist mainly of
weights and multiplications of weights
they have no symbols in them therefore
they are very difficult for us to
understand as humans in a way that will
illuminate how they'll behave in
unfamiliar settings
of course the dream of these models is
that somehow we'll see patterns of
activation or something that look like
this and begin to reveal what is clearly
a tree structure and so you might think
aha the model actually does implicitly
represent constituents or named entities
or other kinds of meaningful unit in
language and then you would feel like
you truly understood it
but of course that never happens instead
what we get when we look at these models
is apparently just a mess of activations
you get the feeling that either there's
nothing systematic happening here or
we're just looking at it incorrectly
I'm gonna awful offer a hopeful message
on this point the mess is only apparent
when we use the right techniques and
take the right perspective on these
models the best of them actually have
found really systematic and interesting
Solutions
there's another angle we could take on
this which connects back to the stuff
about behavioral testing I've showed
this slide a few times in the course
it's progress on benchmarks along the
x-axis we have time and the y-axis is a
normalized measure of distance from our
estimate of human performance in the red
line
and one perspective on this slide is
that progress is incredible benchmarks
used to take us decades to get to
saturate and now saturation happens in a
matter of years
the other perspective on this plot of
course is that the benchmarks are too
weak we have a suspicion that even the
models that are performing well on these
tasks are very far from the human
capability that we are trying to
diagnose we feel that they have brittle
Solutions concerning solutions that are
going to reveal themselves in
problematic ways
to really get past that concern we need
to go beyond this behavioral testing
there's another underlying motivation
for this which is systematicity we
talked about this in detail in the
previous unit it's an idea from frodor
and pilition they say what we mean when
we say that linguistic capacities are
systematic is that the ability to
produce or understand some sentences is
intrinsically connected to the ability
to produce understand certain others
right this is the idea that if you know
what Sandy loves the puppy means then
you just know what the puppy love Sandy
means and if you recognize the
distributional Affinity between the
turtle and the puppy you also understand
the turtle loves the puppy Sandy loves
the turtle and so forth and so on for
suddenly an enormous number of sentences
and the kind of human capacity for
language makes it feels like these
aren't new facts that you're learning
but rather things that follow directly
from an underlying capability that you
have and we offered compositionality as
one possible explanation for why in the
language realm our understanding and use
of language is so systematic
the related Point here is that you get
the feeling that we won't fully trust
our models until we can validate that
the solutions that they have found are
also systematic or maybe even
compositional in this way otherwise
we'll have concerns that at crucial
moments their behaviors will be
arbitrary seeming to us
there's another angle that you can take
on this project of explaining model
behaviors you know the field has a lot
of really crucial high-level goals that
relate to safety and trustworthiness and
so forth right we want to be able to
certify where models can be used and
where they should not be used we want to
be able to certify that our models are
free from pernicious social biases and
we want to offer guarantees that our
models are safe in certain contexts
given what I've said about behavioral
testing you can anticipate what I'll say
now behavioral testing alone will not
suffice to achieve these goals it could
possibly tell us that a model does have
a pernicious social bias or is unsafe in
a certain context or has a certain area
where it should be disapproved for use
but the positive guarantees free from
social bias safe in a context or
approved for a given use those will not
be achieved until we get Beyond
behavioral testing for those we need to
understand
at a deep level what our models are
structured by and how what What
mechanisms guide their behavior we need
analytic guarantees about how they will
behave and that means Beyond behavioral
testing to really understand the causal
mechanisms
in service of moving toward that goal
we're going to discuss as I said three
main methods the first one is probing
there are some precedents before Tenny
at all 2019 in the literature but I
think 10 yet I'll give real credit for
showing that probing was viable and
interesting in the Bert era because what
they did is essentially fit small
supervised models to different layers in
the Bert architecture and what they
discovered is that there is a lot of
systematic information encoded in those
layers this was really eye-opening I
think that most people believed that
even though Bert was performant it was
performant in ways that depended on
entirely unsystematic Solutions and what
probing began to suggest is that Bert
had induced some really interesting
causal structure about language as part
of its training regime
the way this plot works is that we have
the layers of Bert along the x-axis and
we have different phenomena in these
different panels and what you can see in
the blue especially is that different
kinds of information are emerging pretty
systematically at different points in
the Burt layer structure for example
part of speech seems to emerge around
the middle dependency parses emerge a
bit later named entities are kind of
fainter and later in the structure
semantic roles pretty strong near the
middle co-reference information emerging
later in the network and so forth and so
on this was really eye-opening because I
think people didn't anticipate that all
of this would be so accessible in the
hidden representations of these models
what we'll see is that probing is very
rich in terms of characterizing these
internal representations but it cannot
offer causal guarantees that this
information is shaping model performance
so we can complement that with a class
of methods that are called feature
attribution methods the idea here is
that we will essentially in the Deep
learning context study the gradients of
our model and use those to understand
which neurons and which collections of
neurons are most guiding its input
output behavior and for these methods
we're going to get kind of only faint
characterizations of what the
representations are doing but we will
get some causal guarantees
what I've got here to kind of illustrate
is a simple sentiment challenge set
there are a bunch of hard cases
involving attitude taking with verbs
like say and kind of shifts in sentiment
and what you see here in the
highlighting is that the model seems to
be making use of very intuitive
information to shape what are very good
predictions for these cases and again
that might be reassuring to us that the
model is doing something human
interpretable and systematic under the
hood
and then finally we're going to study
intervention-based methods this is a
large class of methods I think I'll save
the details for a later screencast but
the essence of this is that we're going
to kind of perform brain surgery on our
models we are going to manipulate their
internal States and study the effects
that that has on their input output
behavior and in that way we can piece
together an understanding of the causal
mechanisms that shape the model's
Behavior
pushing us toward exactly the kind of
guarantees that we need
so let me by way of wrapping up this
opening screencast offer you a kind of
analytical framework for thinking about
the methods that we're going to discuss
let's say we have three goals first we
want to characterize representations
input representations output
representations but maybe most crucially
internal representations for our models
we also want to make causal claims about
the role of those representations and
once we have started to learn about how
the models behave we would like to have
an easy path to actually improving
models based on those insights so that
we don't simply passively study them but
rather actively make them better
so that's a kind of scorecard let's
think about these methods what we'll see
is that probing is great as I said at
characterizing representations but it
cannot offer causal inferences and it's
unclear whether there's a path from
probing to actually improving models
for future attributions we get only
faint characterizations of the model
internal States we pretty much just get
weights that tell us how much individual
neurons contribute to the input output
Behavior
but we can get causal guarantees from
some of these methods we'll talk about
integrated gradients as an example of
that
and then these intervention-based
methods I've got Smileys across the
board this is the class of methods that
I've been most deeply involved with it's
the class of methods that I favor and
that is in large part because of how
well they do on this scorecard with
these methods we can characterize
representations we can offer causal
guarantees and as you'll see there's an
easy path to using the insights we
gained to actually improve our models
and that's kind of the name of the game
for me
so we will now begin systematically
working through these three classes of
methods trying to more deeply understand
how they work and why my scorecard looks
the way it does